before the video starts guys check our
sponsors and nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10
percent of their products what are you
guys waiting for
[Music]
lady so high-level feed them
I said I wanna commit to a better care
to bother the citizen dear friends
welcome back salam studios today we are
discussing is something something that's
really important that's well we've got
update one
now before we come to this i want to
tell you guys that as you can see once
again innocent lives have been stolen
who by people who are perverted mainly
that's crazy but i know what people
believe that as muslims were immune to
mental illness we can't be mental mental
thank god you know we are immune to that
but anyways the point here is this that
innocent people are going to carry on
being killed now this person who carried
out this vicious attack this person who
over here as we can see himself a close
friend of Anjem Choudary Anjem Choudary
probably sipping in his soup in his tea
in its nice comfy house while he said
says send his little foot soldiers out
there to carry out attacks yeah die
really indirectly he's never going to
claim it directly indirectly so just go
foot soldiers go and carry out this
attack and kill innocent people that's
the reason why we confront his followers
and the far-right follow why because
these people these people benefit off
each other and innocent people like me
and you is going about their business
trying to build a future for their kids
get mowed down or killed stabbed to
death the same thing happened in New
Zealand what do we learn from this as I
had the interview of Tony Robinson
ex-colleague Haider Robertson yeah he
said that when Tony Robinson used to
hear news of these terrorist attacks
whoever is done by but specifically
Muslims he would rejoin she'll be happy
and this is what you've got a perverted
person because he is happy why cuz he's
gonna help his objectives and his goals
what is in this nice mansion
yeah in a Jacuzzi having probably
alcohol or whatever he's having these
people say they're comfy homes while
they send their foot soldiers that carry
out attacks brothers and sisters we need
to put an end to this and this the
reason why we should be vocal and
confront these people if you know
somebody around your neighborhood
or somebody who's crazy like this person
report it to police
yeah and anyone that comes here says oh
no you can't go to the kuffar but
hunting on a believer is an absolute
jahil ignorant person I don't wanna
- yep these people are perverted that's
not when we confront him
they just don't change anyways anyways
now moving on to a more better positive
news yeah along the bridge work of
Mohammed pin down attacker on break and
then return to his work so recently on
this story we know two people innocent
got killed three others were injured if
I'm not mistaken yeah we had a Polish
guy an immigrant who came there used
some kind of a weapon I don't know it's
called to attack the guy also we found
out today that a man a Muslim man called
Mohammed was actually going to work he
went there
pinned the attacker on his break and he
actually returned to work and his boss
actually said that he just came he was
there he held the guy down he came and
got back Washington oh well you know
Washington was - I think I may Allah
bless him and preserve him for his hell
out income but his earning handled is
very important so now the question that
needs to be bette that needs to be asked
firstly it hasn't been highlighted
enough yeah even this article is okay
it's written here but when you go down
it doesn't talk much about it just goes
back to this instead of what happened
this is a listen Mohammed most luckily
Muslim now the question is if we're
going to blame the attack on based on
his religion and said you know what this
is what is religion teaches him then we
need to be consistent because if that's
wise religion teaches then we need to
ask a question what what did his
religion teach to this Mohammed this
brother Mohammed who came to and pinned
the guy so which one is following Islam
the one who's carrying out the attack or
the one who's actually attacking the
attacker the process Adam told us that
there Louis that the one of the lowest
form of a man is to move a harmful
object of the road now this brother
Mohammed he did exactly that he saw this
crazy maniac yeah absolutely yeah and he
had to move him off the road because he
was a harm to people we are told in the
Quran surah Montana chapter 16 verse 8
Allah says Allah does not forbid you
from being just an kinds of those who
did not fight you in based on your faith
because we believe in Allah and kick you
out of your houses unless is that he
doesn't tell us to me not to be kind it
tells us to be kind to these people so
brother
I'm in here who's walking and managed to
pin this guy as well as other brave
heroes we need to understand and say be
consistent with ourself because if
you're going to blame a crazy Muslim and
say that was religious for then you have
to be consistent and if that's the case
then Mohammed also know that from its
religion yeah the first one it can learn
that from his religion why because it's
got nothing to do with this religion it
hasn't but this really doesn't say go
and kill innocent people it doesn't say
that it has verses of more a verses of
four verses of fighting in the
battlefield against an enemy yes and
that is a given with any kind of
soldiers or military yeah so we just
wanted to raise awareness and we should
raise more awareness that a Muslim man
was involved in taking down this crazy
person this person who has ruined
people's lives and these people bring no
benefits if we think about brother and
sisters show me one benefit that these
people bring to Islam just one one thing
they support and they help the
objectives of the far-right more Islamic
forum is more than they will benefit you
ask yourself a question sometimes what
benefit are these people bring in
nothing absolutely nothing and that's
the reason why the Prophet peace be upon
him wound us against these people
they're known as the Hajj they would
warn us against these people anyways
that was a little update for me with the
current affairs that's happening hope
you guys have benefited from the
inshallah share this with your friends
and family and make awareness so people
can see that we as Muslims and if I was
there if my teacher was there we will
found exactly the same thing or worse
this guy because this guy is a biggest
enemy to my religion let alone to the
non-muslims that he deems to be the
compartment he is a bigger enemy and
he's bigger he's putting more against
Islam then forest and so youngsters if
you're watching this do not be
brainwashed do not be the footstool do
not be a foot soldier for those who are
high up making money while they're
ruining your lives
quoting you guys to join Isis and you go
them your lives are ruin anyone
come back here crying and sobbing lives
are being ruined and this is a reason
why we will continue confronting these
people because these people Muslims like
me and people like me
yeah or Mohammed II job or our
surrounded people are under surroundings
we are disbelievers in them we are
apostates this is how brainwashed they
are they have problems in their life and
because that doesn't work out they take
it out on innocent people
hope you guys have benefit Brahmin
sisters if there's any current effects
that you would like me to discuss raise
awareness on comment section below
so next time from Salaam studios Salaam
alaikum what happened to lie better get